I think I probably wrote that in five
weeks of just getting up and like you
know hammering away in it I'll tell you
one thing that also I think there's a
great lesson in
clean your IMDB shows 12 writing credits
I'm sure you've written more scripts
that are just there but of those films
which production taught to you the most
about writing and why Oh interesting
uh you know that we talked about a
little bit earlier the biggest lesson
about writing is get up and do it you
know is like it is a job you know I I'm
the kind of guy that I like a glass of
wine you know I like some music going
that's very romantic
and I'm sure Hemingway would be very
proud but like that's really not how you
get a script done or how you write that
many scripts and I I'm always writing so
it's like you got to get up you got to
spend time with your coffee you got to
look at it and sometimes it's just
sitting there not being able to write
anything that gets you two days later to
where you are where you can you know
answer the question and put it on paper
uh
but I love working on all different
genres like that's what's always fun to
me is getting hired to do you know like
a punch-up on a kids movie or here's a
horror film or you know here's a family
drama but like I love getting to do all
of them because I love movies and it's
it gets boring doing the same thing over
and over again
so as far as like what taught me the
most I think it was just it's just being
throwing the random here I need you to
do this suspense action film for me you
know and like sometimes you'll get a
finished script and you'll fix it
sometimes you'll get a paragraph and
you'll execute it you know it's like so
yeah I don't know all of them I guess
it's just the process of writing you
just get better at it and like that's
something I tell young people all the
time is like you get practing the more
you write so you have to write you know
I mean all the time I know is manic you
said that kind of showed you that you
wanted to direct up for the various
reasons right and then with weathergirl
it sounds like being and so in an
uncomfortable situation we pushed you
how I did that script take whether go
that that script almost wrote itself
like when I think of like the easiest
right
experiences that I think I probably
wrote that in five weeks of just getting
up and like you know hammering away in
it I'll tell you one thing that also I
think there's a great lesson in
directing your own script because you
find in the editing room if there are
flaws in your script in your logic and
your plotline you will find it in
editing and it's crazy to me it's like
six month all I got almost no notes on
that script that script everybody dug
that script like it was just one of
those things like sometimes as a writer
it's just like something will resonate
and people just liked it they're like he
talks a little too much and you know but
of Annette Mike great but then we got
into editing and I have all of these
structural problems like he has this
moment where he realizes he loves a girl
twice now why didn't I see that why
didn't anyone read the script say this
moment happens twice but nobody did you
know and like it's made me look at
script a lot harder now especially my
own like when is this moment in the
movie like and this has to be this
special moment it can't be duplicated
like because we had to move a lot of
things around I had this great editor a
BLEVE who helped me you know streamline
that that story that in a proper world
should have been streamlined on the page
know what I mean so with weathergirl how
much do you think you really I don't
know I'm just I'm just trying to
envision that time for you do you think
with some of the other productions you
were more comfortable and it was harder
to finish it um in terms of the script
and in terms of the script
I I think you know I didn't have TV I
had uh it was really it's really
depressing
I had this season of the office that I
would watch over and over and over again
and so like I didn't really have
anything to do except for sit there and
write which was the by design you know I
didn't get cable I'd you know I just
wanted to work and it was actually
easier then to write and say you know
when you're happy with a girlfriend
you know it's like that's that's the
hardest time for me to write is when I'm
you know happy and dizzy when I just
moved that from New York and I love
living in New York because so much to do
it's hard for me to write New York
because I'm always distracted by you
know things that are going on outside
you know or what's my roommate doing
down there you know it sounds like he's
having fun you're drinking beer let me
have some beer so you know sometimes
that that that lonely time is it's
actually easier you know so from being a
bartender I know you're probably busy
making drinks and getting customers
orders but you probably had some moments
when you could see the LA crowd from
this other perspective
yeah and how much did you see some of
that in the patrons that went there even
though you don't really know their
personal life right on everybody's
putting on this happy facade I needed to
get out of Los Angeles after 6 month
roll after 6 months ago I had kind of
hit this I was supersaturated with Los
Angeles you know I've been here for a
really long time since I was 19 years
old kid actor went to UCLA you know like
I've been in this town for a long time
and I just need it out because I think
what you're saying because of like I saw
the stereotypes I saw the you know the
LA shallowness or whatever and I thought
me you know which was not good either
and I just it's not what I wanted so I
fled to New York and enjoyed my time
very much there and I've just moved back
here you know for business wise and LA
is different to me now like I I have
perspective you know I see that you know
it's not the stereotypes that I was
seeing you know when I was when I was
here before I was painting my own
unhappy picture of it but it's actually
not that better place I think I just
been here too long so and I've heard the
same thing about people have been in you
oh and here's I think it's just a change
of atmosphere yeah true I have friends
who've lived in New York much longer
than I did you know they're like I'll
tell them how much I love it don't be
like I try five more years like well
maybe you should give it a break maybe
have to go somewhere else that's what I
did but you're also coming here with a
film yes coming out that has
distribution so I'm sure that's got to
feel great it's also
different you're coming from a different
situation and yeah I mean you know the
thing about like this movie business
is really weird it's really weird
because it's like it has so many
different levels it's like you start and
you got the script and you gotta try to
raise the money and then that's the
whole thing and then you get the money
and then you have to put it together and
then that whole thing I love being on
set being on set is my absolute favor
when I'm on set and then you were
rapping then your go into
post-production which I'm not my best me
but like it's part of it and then you
have to get the distribution and then
you get to do the film festivals and now
you're here literally we get a link
later today for the pre-sales
of cut to the chase and then in three
weeks it'll be out and everybody in
America will be able to access it and
that's kind of like the end really I
mean will come out on DVD in June so
that'll be a whole other thing that
we'll deal with but like for all
practical purposes this journey is
ending next month and like I'm just
really excited not for it to be over but
for this you know pinnacle of like here
we are we made it to the crest you know
good job everybody what's next
you